auto pilot c'est le nom d'un nouveau
projet européen qui vise à élaborer la
voiture autonome de demain en france
l'institut versailles avait des com a
été sélectionné pour mener les
recherches cinq autres pays européens
sont impliqués dans ce programme d'un
coût de 25 millions d'euros
le but principal du projet c'est de
relever le niveau d'automatismes dans le
véhicule en utilisant un nombre
important d'objets connectés qui vont
permettre de fournir des informations à
levante pour l'environnement du vvd
comme travaillera sur des renault twizy
qui sont des petits véhicules
électriques
son objectif est de pouvoir les rendre
autonomes grâce à ses capteurs et
logiciels embarqués
c'est évidemment l'avenir et d'ailleurs
tous les constructeurs automobiles eux
réfléchissent aujourd'hui ce véhicule
autonome
c'est un marché énorme la ville de
versailles a équipé le centre ville pour
que ces véhicules puissent se déplacer
sans conducteur le projet auto pilot ne
vise pas seulement à développer des
technologies d'autonomie mais aussi à
rendre le véhicule communicant la
voiture autonome va devoir se connecter
ici pour connaître son environnement ce
soit pour connaître par exemple des
conditions météo
reconnaître les conditions de trafic
pour connaître son environnement on
envisage aussi qu'elle pourra interagir
avec les smartphones des piétons des
cyclistes histoire de réduire en partie
le nombre d'accidents de
de la route d'ici à 2018 et l'ambition
de bd comme et de mettre au point qu'un
zordo twizy autonome et communicante
elles seront dans un premier temps
destiné au transport de touristes autour
du château de versailles
mais les recherches se poursuivront il y
à des freins techniques et aussi des
freins financiers
aujourd'hui ce sont des voitures de
démonstration de recherche
on les a bardé de capteurs barre des
deux systèmes
technologique embarqué il est clair que
on ne peut pas mettre ça dans la voiture
de monsieur tout le monde et la vendant
toujours un prix raisonnable
le défi faire baisser le coût de toutes
ces technologies afin de rendre le
véhicule autonome accessible au grand
public